tournament talk
so as you guys know we talked about my
chess experience not too long ago on the
podcast
and i got a little reminiscent and i
tweeted out saying hey we should do an
anime youtuber chess tournament because
[ __ ] it why not and chess.com
promptly emailed me within an hour
saying hey do you want to
want to set that up i want us to help
you do that and i was like
uh yeah so i tweeted out asking who
wanted to join and now we have
the tournament arc that's the name of
the chess we are
we don't have a chess anime so we're
making our own right here we're making
our own chess anime so this is a special
episode of trash taste where it's not so
much a podcast as more
our experience and how the tournament
goes and we're recording this before the
tournament takes place
and this is basically our initial
thoughts how we think it's all going to
go
and yeah i guess that's kind of it
really so do we want to talk about the
the fact that this is actually going to
be a legit esports tournament because
because we have like we have like a cash
pool yeah we do
prizes and everything so first place
gets two grand second place gets a grand
third place eight hundred fourth place
four hundred and then fifth through to
eight
gets two hundred so yeah doesn't matter
if you lose first game
because i know i am yeah i'm still going
home with 200 bucks
you know you if if you lose you still
win exactly
exactly everyone's a winner there's
literally a participation award for this
one
it's 200 bucks that's the best
participation dude what else are you
gonna spend your money on but more
gadget money i'm putting that right into
arc night
so yeah this is a completely legit chess
tournament arranged very officially
they've taken a lot of measures to stop
us from cheating not that any of us
would
gentlemen um but yeah here are the eight
contestants how we selected them
was obviously me judging if you're a
good anti-tuber no that's not what i
want
people assumed that was what it was no i
literally just tweeted out
that was the case and half of these
people wouldn't be here
we got these contestants i tweeted out
who wants to be in it and then i gave
the list of
to chess.com and they selected these
three people so here we are
and yeah we have the very anticipated
first game of
gaunt versus mother's basement i'm so
[ __ ] ready for this
so [ __ ] [ __ ] talking you guys are
doing on twitter was one of the funniest
it was it was the most it was the
funniest and somehow the most pathetic
thing ever it was
like baby mode [ __ ] talking though it
was it was no
you that's what it was another game
excited for is d versus jerry
yeah d was talking mad [ __ ] to me on
discord
i saw a d [ __ ] i saw you just
being like joey i know you're up
fight me bro fight me and i'm just like
this is chill
it's funny because i saw dee tweeted
earlier that he's like oh i'm going for
the underdog
the underdog root in this tournament and
behind the scenes he's been talking mad
[ __ ]
he's so confident about himself but i
mean
i mean rightfully so i've you know as we
let you know as i said in the chess
episode i've never played a game of
chess up until this point so
i've learned been learning a lot but i
still suck dick but
i think you know the only person who has
nhs experience in this tournament is me
but outside of that
and even then i still make really dumb
mistakes um i think
it'll be an interesting tournament just
because of how much of a [ __ ] mess
bottom line this is going to be the
lowest iq tournament
this is going to be a dummy thick chess
tournament that makes it so fun because
i know that when i'm going to watch any
of your games that it's going to be a
[ __ ] fiesta and
i can't wait to see what happens like i
know it's going to be
it's going to be like when a movable
object meets a stoppable force
i'm also excited to see sydney play
chess just in general that's gonna be
interesting i taught sydney how to play
chess like last weekend yeah
it was uh did she know how to play no
at all no not even remotely any clue of
what any piece did so and
i've seen rustage man he's been playing
a [ __ ] ton so i think
russ is is actually going through his
training arc is actually going to go
through like the underdog
so i'm excited to see you know if maybe
that's going to be a stomp i
i think it might be and then obviously
me versus john i have no idea how good
john is
i'm guessing he's just okay well unless
he's unless he's a hidden chest
the best game is in the first round me
and john battle of the whip you got to
get the [ __ ] talking out though because
you know john loves wrestling so he you
know he's going to be on board i need to
see jon's into it first right when he's
into it i'm alright let's go let's go
hard like
so who's who's the protagonist of this
because i think i have to be the
antagonist right because everyone's like
i'm the guy who's probably gonna be
cocky i've already won a bunch
i know you're like the final boss yeah
it's how i say you're the final boss i
don't know who the protagonist is okay
someone on this side right because the
the protagonist never goes on the same
side of the bracket as the antagonist
that's just not how it works everyone
knows this i think it's gonna be more
like just like a slice of life where
you're the protagonist and everybody
else is the side character you know like
this
there's no antagonist in this story i'm
gonna make sure i'm the antagonist i'm
gonna be an [ __ ]
connor's out here playing code gears and
we're just out here playing chaon
we're just like yay fun times with
friends
i just want to be against one of you two
in the finals no i i want the old trash
taste semi-final then
it has to be yeah that's that's all i
want yeah if we if we get that
we're all winners because we get content
because we're gonna go through a whole
training arc so in this video you're
gonna see us
our initial thoughts we're gonna go home
we're gonna record what we think what
we're gonna do for training
our game plan uh and then you're gonna
see our training sessions with the the
grand masters of chess
yeah and then you'll see the final yeah
so we get a one hour session all of us
with the grand master basically just to
get like a
a last minute tutorial from the very
best so hopefully
we'll be able to uh input enough
information from him and these are the
best of the best man like
i think normally if you want to try and
hire the guys uh for some chess practice
it's not cheap
yeah yeah right and we get paid yeah and
we get paid to do it
right gentlemen so good luck with your
training arcs thank you i wish
any of you stand a chance of beating me
no we want i might as well just give you
the two grand now
as you guys know from the podcast i have
experience as a kid which
let's be honest i'm nowhere near as good
as i used to be and i've forgotten a lot
of things and i make a [ __ ] ton of
mistakes but
i think i still have that like that like
hard-wired
awareness of the board and how the
pieces move and where they are and stuff
at the time and
all the options you can do i'm pretty
sure i'm gonna win
is if i don't [ __ ] up and i just
play good i will win
that's like the same with any sport i
guess so my first match is again super
ipatchwolf he's a total mystery to all
of us
we have zero idea if eyepatch is good at
chess
i'm going into a blind i don't think
he's going to be that amazing so if i
just play normally
it should be fine and then i think in
the semis i'll be against rustage who
i'm a little worried about he's been
streaming a lot and he's been playing a
ton of games and then in the finals
if i had to bet on it i think it'll be
against gone i feel like god is going to
win against mother's basement
and i think that joey might win against
d that that game's going to be a roller
coaster d versus joey it could go anyway
and i think that gaunt would beat joey
i'm hoping hoping that we get that
semi-final i really want those two to
face each other but either way we all
know i'm the final boss of this arc
i'm going to win this it's not going to
be difficult and i'm going to clown and
flex whilst i do it
i want to become the true antagonist of
this
tournament
i don't know if that's going to turn out
well so yeah i'm going to be completely
honest
i am not feeling confident at all i
haven't played chess since i was in
school so that was like when i was what
9
to 11 years old it's been a very long
time since i last played chess
and i've played a few practice games
i've played on chess.com
got completely destroyed online and also
just played a game against joey where
each of us tried to see
who could basically hint harder in the
match it was
god damn awful it didn't even stale mate
but even if one of us had won
both of us had already felt like we had
lost so yeah i'm not feeling too
confident i know joey's not feeling too
good either
conor's probably by himself laughing
because he feels like he's already won
this or something so what i'm gonna try
and do
is my style of studying and what that
means is
i'm not gonna read a book or anything
i'm just going to try and
fail as many times as i can and
hopefully by the time we reach the
tournament
i would have seen so many ways to fail i
won't fail the same way and when i play
my real official matches
overall though i'm just here to have fun
i'm not here to win i'm pretty sure
connor's got this in the bag already
what i really want to do
is just not make a [ __ ] fool of
myself on the tournament
what up it's the chess man as in i
really suck at the chess man so if you
guys may know
uh before this whole tournament thing
even started
your boy had never even touched the
chessboard in his life so suffice it to
say that
i don't have the highest expectations of
myself going into this tournament so i
think we already know that conor's
already going to win
this tournament i think that's just a
given w at this point considering that
everybody else in the tournament
is kind of a beginner especially myself
and the first person i'm up against is
dee from rebel house and i have
no idea if he's any good or not or if he
absolutely sucks dick like i do and i
don't really have much of like a
game plan or anything like that i i
think
the one problem that i personally have
with the couple of games that i have
played
um obviously i'm probably gonna learn a
lot more once i actually go into my
coaching session with japanese tutor but
i think currently my biggest problem is
just that i know
all of the rules and i know like the
gist of how pieces move and stuff like
that but i don't really have like
a open mind as to like how do i attack
what pieces do i use what even
constitutes is a good move and a total
like
loss so yeah i think at this point for
me it's just a matter of
just practicing a lot and just hopefully
with more practice just getting
used to the patterns and actually seeing
the patterns because again like all the
games are going to be timed right we
only have like 10 minutes per game so
i don't have a lot a whole lot of time
to kind of sit there and contemplate
every single move in detail although i
will say that if i managed to
just nail a game if i just managed to
get one w
with the cleanest checkmate ever like
and like i don't even want to like win
from like running out of a time limit
right or even drawing like i i want to
get that w
if i can just get one checkmate then
i'll be satisfied honestly because
god forbid i'm not gonna get past the
first round i want to show you a very
famous game
and this is the called the opera again
so when you're climbing a ladder right
you don't climb a ladder like
this and then this is your phrase it's
called pp on the pp
[Music]
put pressure on the pinned piece okay
okay
you play e4 and you're gonna either take
or you're gonna push and that is going
to change the whole dynamic of the game
oh
man well i went i went from a forehead
to a five head uh yeah is it bishop to
f4 are you a fan of jrpgs by any chance
because this is
very indicative of your playing style
you're playing a one player game
this is actually called the fools i i'm
just one of those guys who if i see an
opportunity to castle i'm just like yeah
let's just castle i just
i don't know if you see that they move
that six there should be an alarm here
so
the name of the game at least in the
opening is the center this is this is
like thinking five moves ahead and i'm
just thinking two or three moves ahead
so what happens when queen captures
bishop on e4
uh then the king is going to take it and
move to each um a lot of people are
saying it's you versus
honor in the uh final oh really oh
that should be interesting a lot of
people are saying i mean connor's like
conor's trying to build himself up as
the main antagonist so i don't know what
that makes me right now
i'm just i'm still trying to figure out
uh what my role is and all this
i just so
jt they're going to be playing rapid
chess
which is uh the the actual time control
is gonna be 10 minutes on the clock
with uh a five seconds added every move
they make we call that an increment all
right everybody we're back
i hope you enjoyed that and now we are
with the guys from trash taste we got
the anime man sea dog va
and giga what's up guys yo hello
all three of you have trained with
japanese tutor and the other four
competitors got an hour of training with
national master james canty so how did
your coaching sessions go and like what
did your fans think was it too much for
them
yeah i mean i really enjoyed it just
because i think
out of the three of us here like i
before
the talks of this tournament even
started i had never even touched a chess
piece in my life
it was like actually completely new
experience for me i tried to teach
myself beforehand before
i got in the coaching session with jt
but obviously
jt schooled me really hard i'm probably
gonna lose i'll do my best
but you know at least i can say that i
got
uh some good coaching what about you gig
how's your uh
1.5 player chess strategy going
yeah i i actually went into the coaching
chess session thinking i was pretty bad
at chess
i was surprised where we were just
reviewing this very
high level game i was surprised that
that was
the the route that jt thought was best
for me but it was very
very helpful actually it was uh it gave
me a different perspective of how to
think of the game
and i think my audience very much
enjoyed it as well compared to like my
previous streams people
seem very very engaged and very
interested in chess as a whole
it's also something that i've like found
and you interested in
interest in as well because i hadn't
played since
school before this tournament so it's
been very fun getting back into it and
uh conor jt came prepared with some
historic
chess games as well for you guys to look
at right one of them was a
gary casserov game right and there was
another one with some dudes who had an
opera or something i can't remember
yeah that's great yeah yeah that's
that's all i remember yeah they were
good games
i feel that i'm much smarter
in like a puzzle sense right when i can
see and i know there's
there is a solution but when it's my own
games i'm like
i don't know i'm just moving things
but overall i mean i really enjoyed our
lesson i think my viewers did too
i mean they loved the pp on the pp
great teaching method i'm pretty sure
i've got the w
anyway you know it was nice having a
lesson to secure it
wow well connor i've got a next question
for you so you know i've been watching
all the activity on twitter and it seems
like the twittersphere
has decided that you're the villain in
this storyline
i don't want to be modest i mean that's
no fun the tournament needs a villain so
why not you know i mean it sounds like
you're you're at peace with that or
or i don't know i'm fine with that it's
fun the villain never gets to win but
we'll change that we'll change that with
this tournament
i feel like every time i know we've
played with a physical board we've had
like our own
training training arcs together and it's
i don't know it's
it's different playing with a physical
board i feel like i play with
like 10 percent less brain power when
i'm when i'm playing with a physical
board just because i'm so used to the
chess.com ui
that's secret yeah yeah find yourself
standing like
way above it so you get that direct down
view
yes it's because the chest.com ui is so
clean
that i sometimes look at the board and
it's just like a mess of information
that i just don't know what's going on
anymore
yeah it's like why can't i draw arrows
in real life and like pre-move
why can't i do that when we played in
real life you know what i missed the
most i'm like damn i want to know if
that was a good move i wish the
there was analysis on for this i want to
know if
that was like a big brain move or a dumb
i don't know what a beautiful event
right like
eight of your favorite youtubers
battling it out
yes over the 64 squares and we're going
to start out with rustage versus sid
snap
i'm super stoked for this like what do
you what do you think is going to happen
in this first match
i think there are going to be a lot of
blunders and
a lot of exciting chess yeah i mean i
i've watched them practice and they're
both attackers
right so this is going to be these games
are going to be nuts i think
and you know you mentioned the engine so
i want to point out for anyone watching
who is not sure what that bar is
on the left-hand side there of the uh
the chessboard
that is going to be sort of like a
living engine analysis
of what the what the advantage is
in the current position as the game goes
so if the white bar gets larger that
means the engine believes that white is
doing better in a sort of pure
evaluation if everyone were to play
perfect moves
from that position on then that would
represent what the current advantage is
and obviously if black's bar is bigger
then it's
trying to tell you that black is
probably doing better it may be much
better the bar might be
almost completely solid black and at
that point black is probably not that
far away from finding a good checkmate
this is a
best of two effectively they will play
one game with each color so
starting as white and starting as black
they only need a win
and a draw in order to win their match
for this round so 1.5 points right
that's one point for a win
half a point for a draw obviously a loss
is zero
so whoever can get 1.5 or better is
gonna take it and the game has started
all right let's do this
sid snap starts with the white pieces
that bishop move kind of goes for her
style right it's like just get her
pieces out there
throw in a check see what he does and
then she's castled i mean they're both
doing great they're developing they're
castling like wow
oh ouch town
ah there it goes that's the first botez
gambit of the tournament
and sid is not happy with that and we'll
get sid's audio here
she is
she's feeling the pressure for sure so i
blocked this file
23 seconds remaining i got it she's in a
must-win situation i do like the control
that she has
over e4 now if we don't blunder
the queen away here okay great
[Laughter]
it's over rustage wins his first match
as you can see he's absolutely
losing his mind next gigguk
vs mother's basement players are
ready and we are off the game has begun
mother's basement starts out with the
white pieces yeah everybody seems to
have really really been doing some
serious practice here
oh no not my queen out oh that's
how that turned out oh no oh no
is avoiding knight e5 just avoiding it
every single move and it's a great
square for your knight right
right in the center of the board can't
quickly be
uh pushed out of the way by a pawn bring
this a little further up and put
pressure on that bishop no and then i
will potentially trade my queen but
okay he's trying to come up with a plan
i'm loving how he's thinking he's like
hey i have to keep developing i have to
connect my rooks right
this is an awesome plan i'm not going to
tell them
well here's a critical moment for giga
let's uh try to listen in and see if we
can hear him
oh that's going to be costly what an
amazing
turn of events i mean yeah i'm running
outside let's see what jeff does on the
press show okay so he's basically saying
like i'm going to control my clock by
just issuing
some threats and he just gave back the
peace oh no
if f3 takes on g4 we have knight e4
the same tactic that uh mother's
basement had
now he has it in reverse yes i like how
much tension there are
in these games so far i mean like you
know everybody
has chances in these middle games all
right well let's take a peek in and
listen in
mother's basement and see oh yeah what
is going on
whereas if i move my he's got some hype
music happening
so interesting he castled in this
position where maybe he didn't see that
the bishop was free he should have taken
his bishop that now he realizes he
needed that bishop and that's just kind
of hanging out there in the middle now
not doing much
i'm going to take his bishop giga can
close this thing out he's got a lot of
choices
and a lot of good things work here
there's your move 194
yeah yeah 94 is a very strong move and
again in these structures 94 is perfect
because you want to fill in those
squares and this is called an
outpost actually having a very strong
move rook captures a2
threatening checkmate on the next move
yes speaker with uh rook to a1
oh there we go there we go okay
i wonder if it's gonna see this play
your 1.5 player chest don't worry about
what he's doing anymore there we go
there we go there it is
there we go big brain oh this is exactly
what we were talking about in our lesson
[ __ ] i've blundered oh man he hasn't
blundered yet because there's a lot of
pressure it doesn't matter about our
king side anymore
we're attacking on the queen side our
queen side attack is worth
more than a rook right now i mean that's
all right right yeah yeah
i think we he still keeps his advantage
if we were able to play like something
like queen c6
and get in there we still have checkmate
opportunities
so i like the plan and he only has 50
seconds left
right that that is also a factor oh wow
yeah mother's basement is definitely
feeling the pressure on the clock
bishop d6 very nice mother's basement
down to 10 seconds
uh-oh oh wow living on increment right
now this works right getting the queen
involved
oh there we go
oh and he he says let's let's let's
let's throw in a check
then we'll take the free stuff you have
this yep okay
nice nice now you just have to wrap it
up it's a lot of pressure
and there's your move before yeah great
move break everything open
exactly and we may just see a loss on
time here and we
have time exactly gets the first game
mother's basement now in a must-win
position he's got to win the next game
and is stoked he says one more boys here
we go
gigook with the white pieces now we
gonna see just some
all-out attacking is he gonna he's gonna
take it to the next level here
i really i'm interested in how he plays
[Music]
i think here um we just kind of really
want to trick pieces
although it's not over right this is
still anybody's game it's only a piece
this man is tilted to [ __ ] man oh oh
jeff but be careful gig don't let that
confidence get to your head i shall
reinforce that pawn
okay so he's just going for a stable
development it's good
he's really bunched up there okay i
think even though i'm down a piece i'm
in a better position overall
you know the eval says this is all for
white but i think there's chances for
for either player still i gotta learn
how to play this more aggressively
i think like like i gotta learn how to
like trade effectively that's
my big weakness is he already talking
about this game like it's
identified yeah i think he's he's
defeating himself and
we see queen d4 on the board like wow
wow
wow i i wonder if they know the
ambassador i wonder if he knows
c5 now the white yes and white tape
let's go he sees it a rule that a lot of
people a lot of beginners especially
don't remember that if the
if the opponent's pawn tries to skip
past
in order to not be captured on that next
turn you can take as if it had only
moved one space
and now it's busted wide open let's go
this is forced
it's over geek has sealed the deal
he has no choice he has to move there he
knows he's got it in the bag he's moving
on
yep only one move oh and he's savoring
it man this win was so free and i didn't
even have to use coupon choice basement
a little bit of trash talk there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's go let's go
let's [ __ ] go and there it is it's
over
he celebrates he's moving on we got d
getting ready he's talking to his chat
oh look he's saying like
you know i hope the universe is with me
on this one
they're both really nervous but really
hype
you can see it in both of those races
they're they're ready for this well i
know everybody
in the chat uh across all platforms is
also ready
and so the games have started here we go
and d gets the white pieces to start
very nice smooth
yes perfect okay controlling the center
immediately both of them keep developing
our minor pieces exactly what we talked
about you see they're playing perfect
chests here he's playing safe so
what would i counter with because do we
want to start off with an exchange
straight away
not really after that fill this out the
best thing to do
please just hear it for me wow for me
[ __ ] up
it's calculating right now the sacrifice
is not it's not sound and what i mean by
not sound i mean
it's it's uh it's not good yeah you're
just you're just giving up a
a piece that was doing fine right where
it was for a measly pawn
what is happening here you can just see
it in his face right now that he's uh
he's totally bewildered i'm gonna have
to take the l with the queen to be
honest
what hmm he's saying he's gonna let him
have the queen
what the queen ki is cannot go anywhere
the queen is trapped
all of these squares are covered wait he
does not take the queen
what is happening either they have the
biggest brains
in all of chess history or i don't know
what's happening i
i think it's just i think they're just
so nervous i think they're
both they both want this so bad yeah put
it
put put a little bit more pressure on
him i'm i'm also banking on joey to [ __ ]
up
and if i'm lucky enough he just might
he's putting how much emphasis on
joey making mistakes as he is on
his ability to make good moves i think
right what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
move the
rock here just so i can kind of aim for
this
open spot good idea more control over
the center right yeah
and now he he's probably thinking that
he wants to like go into this diagonal
to try and
check mating me here but i got the queen
and the rook here so
i'm safe feeling so he's gonna try and
go for this diagonal we normally
only look at the piece that moves right
we say okay this bishop move
so what is he trying to do with the
bishop exactly
instead of that say okay the bishop
moves but what not
what opens right yeah and that's a that
that's about
you know you're kind of like thinking
about space as well as material a lot of
people focus on just material in the
beginning
but space is obviously very important
because you could lose some serious
material if you're not paying attention
easy as possible oh this is a really
nice attack on the queen
please don't blunder the queen really
really nice attack the bishop
moves on the diagonal let's see what is
going to happen is he going to notice it
yep it's defended you can't take it you
got to move okay oh
this is a really nice move basically
saying your queen has nowhere to go and
if we trade queens i'm just gonna be up
two pieces
i'm already up on material i'm i'm gonna
do better than you in the end game
best thing i can do really all right
i'm gonna try and pressure his bishop
here he's only thinking maybe like one
ply deep right now you know he needs to
do more than that right yeah pressure
the bishop okay but then what
i think just trading down is the anime
man's best friend
oh and now this opens up to the diagonal
so now we might have a very
interesting combination here oh very
nice i mean this is this is
this is textbook for black there is a
checkmate if he sees it
move the king away yeah
there he found it he knows he's got
he doesn't realize he could take it with
the bishop it's okay it's okay
he still has a lot of pieces to go it's
about to be checked mate
wait how's that on check night only one
move and
let's go oh that feels so good
and he does it oh
oh oh no are anybody saying oh no it's
because of
you can take it two ways he misses it he
misses it he doesn't see he could take
with the queen he could take with the
knight
that was a free piece they going through
some tunnel vision here
i haven't been practicing as much as i
should okay just throw this here
and if he wants to up the pressure he
will try and take that but he doesn't
well you know one of the reasons why we
talk so much about opening principles
right is to reduce the amount of like
deep thinking you have to do in those
first opening moves
you know if you stick to principles
you're probably going to be able to
develop safely
and so you shouldn't have to be buried
too deep in thought
in these opening stages right and then
you burn all this time on your clock
you need that time later in the game
this is still anybody's game
what did we just see here that was just
an even exchange a bishop for a night
but that bishop
is usually pretty good in these kind of
structures
oh oh
the queen does he see it does he see it
oh no oh no
does he see it d this may be the whole
match right here
if d has to fight this second game with
no queen
can we listen to the enemy man why did
he do that but
he's he's got his mouse over the rook no
no no oh
night can't really go anywhere he's not
even talking about the queen oh my god
she misses it
it doesn't see the queen is right there
for the tape
are you trying to like go here to like
infiltrate this side as well leave it
there
because if that's the case then i can
just take with the knight okay d gives a
check but
i mean you're queen and now the problem
with this of course is he's got
two pieces under attack at the same time
he's going to lose his knight no matter
what next time
every piece is covered except these two
so he's gonna have to move the knights
back to these two places
okay sure and now somehow
somehow d has wiggled out that night
d also has a forced mate because the
queen has to go here
yep oh
oh my gosh oh my god i see it does he
see it
causing him to try and move somewhere
safe but is anywhere safe
he missed it anime man missed it he
could take on g7
wait it's still the anime man's turn and
d has no
idea that he is about to get mated
luckily this game
i haven't [ __ ] up i keep fingering my
camera's over there
this game i haven't haven't [ __ ] up
royally
so
i say that i see that
i see that and that's it anime man moves
forward
he is super pumped fists
pumping he's got the victory music
playing and there you have it next
up is sea dog e
a versus super eye patch wolf
there's a lot of talk about sea dogs
experience and now they want to see if
he can put the money where the mouth is
oh [ __ ] we're here the game has begun
what okay okay what are we going to do
here and i think what i want to do is i
want to try and castle on my
king's side so i'm gonna go here
okay see dog what you got he's not
rushing in here
which makes me that makes me happy
another key
is that this bishop doesn't belong here
because you're blocking in this bishop
um he's really taken that time yikes
oh okay huh okay that's uh that's
interesting why would he do that
i'm just saying he doesn't know why he's
here putting a lot of pressure on him
let's see if he goes through it
i really want a castle as well at some
point i feel like um
being able to check we had an extra bank
of france and he used it wisely to
understand the position and knight t5
was probably one of the best moves there
okay i think this is the right move oh
that's interesting you know i'm actually
really impressed here because
you know we were expecting very like
aggressive
play from sea dog with uh with all the
confidence that he
seems to have in his ability to make it
to the finals according to social media
but
uh he's playing a very patient game
that's an
interesting move because again what's
what's weird meow is there's nothing
directly offensive in his movements like
he's not
going for it yet and so i think what i
want to start doing is i want to apply a
little pressure
yeah and sea dog foresaw this move this
uh
this might be one of the things that
he's thinking about right now oh
oh oh no
oh no and he knows it
he we see his reaction on camera he it
it settles in and but we'll see dog see
it does he not see it
he's in a really dangerous spot and i
get a rook out of this trade if he takes
this is really bad for him i don't know
why he moved his queen there that was
interesting what a big brain move
wow seems like he's lost the thread here
the fact that he's castling now makes me
think he's taking it seriously now
i will sacrifice a bishop for a rook no
problem
it sounds like eye patch thinks that sea
dog was just clowning him by not taking
the queen
i wanted to no no no no
[ __ ] oh no no that's bad that's really
bad okay bad anime take number two
tales of earth c wasn't that bad it was
a perfectly fine movie
um [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i'm okay with that oh it's
happening it's happening the news is
closing
um okay bad take number three school
days is a work of
genius it's such a good anime and no one
thinks it is
so if you're wondering why he's uh he's
giving
uh opinions about anime after
ever every peace blender i think that
they
have come to an agreement pre-match that
uh when they drop pieces
they have to give an unpopular take
about uh an anime or a manga
and uh it's it's a nice little uh like a
side game i could get my rook involved
actually as well
let's see if he finds it he's he might
be tunnel vision
about that bishop being under attack but
if you ignore it oh
you've got a win let me calculate this i
think i can mate him now
okay he's thinking about checkmate sure
and that patience is on display in full
sea dog sees it and he is going to
secure the first
game in this match surgical surgical win
boys
very nice always humble of course of
course of course
and that's me
pog i think he knows that i'm trying to
castle because if he takes out that guy
i could take him out with my queen and
then he has me in checkmate
and i am not letting that happen so
instead i think what i'm gonna
do is i'm gonna put a little pressure on
him
i'm pretty sure he was trying to counter
my castle there sea dog
seems like he's really soaking this in
he feels maybe like he's already got it
in the bag at this point let's let's
find out
i mean i guess that's not a terrible
move let's please
please tell me he sees this i hope he
spots that i'm pressuring his queen i
really i really do hope he spots it i
really don't want to take his queen
because then the game's just a hundred
percent over and like there's no fun
anymore
like last game was fun dude he made me
think eyepatch gets queen city good
good 91 very sneaky
very small why would he do that that's
such a weird move
knights are terrible in the corner
because you cut off most of their
options
so the only place he can go is here and
here that's such a strange move
we're not gonna overthink it let's just
see it as a blessing from god
there's danger there's a reason you have
to ask yourself why would he do that
because now my queen can go here he goes
and obviously
conor knows exactly why he's putting his
knight in that corner i'm gonna do it
there it is he's committed aggression
will win me this game
so it's pretty i think you just gave me
a snipe for free right i can trade if
you take it
even better cd even better could force a
check as well
yeah keep thinking on your opponent's
move as well this is pretty much over i
think
he's in a really awful position and i
can swing my bishop into this fight at
any moment gotta make some quick
decisive moves here run king run why
would he do that
oh [ __ ] just trying to find safe ground
huh
ah he's totally trying to draw me out
again
he's such a sneaky [ __ ] oh it's the
only move i have ah no
no that's it we're going down we're
going down
uh let's move this to here
no let's not let's move this to here at
this point i'm just i'm just scoring
points like i'm go i have 11 seconds
left i'm dead like i'm finished
yeah i should just castle i'm just gonna
do it nothing wrong with that right
nothing wrong at all or just up three
pieces okay
i have so much time i don't need to
worry what if he takes those pawns
that's not a problem no let's make him
sweat
what is he doing okay he's just throwing
the game
john let me end you know what
[ __ ] it i'ma take all his pieces so he
really is the villain he's the
antagonist
the villain emerges okay what is he
doing what
the god damn it bro all right here it is
and that's it you won by checkmate
wow that was fun and that's it sea dog
sea dog uh holds his enthusiasm because
he knows he's got a long road ahead of
him this is just one of many matches
that he is going to have to face before
getting to the finals i'm so excited for
this matchup i think that these guys
have been hoping
since we announced the tournament uh for
a chance to face each other
and they have it and the game has kicked
off the anime
man uh starts the first game is black
and we'll have white in the second game
up are we going to trade queens here and
then we're going to trade queens oh
okay did he forget which direction
pieces are moving that was the fastest
queen exchange i've ever seen
damn god's coming in for the kill dude
that knight is lost
and he doesn't realize it because the
pawns have swapped positions
ouch
it's sinking in now and he's trying to
make me double up my pawns
also i totally missed that night i don't
know what i was thinking there what i do
is i move my rook there take that and
then i'll pressure this pawn
i'm not gonna give him any breathing
room joey i'm sorry my boy
uh oh now this rook if i get this rook
here and this rock's not here then i can
just boop and then that'll be checkmate
he's trying to prevent me from going to
the e file
and i think what he's trying to do is
the exact same thing he's got this d
file open
so i need to start opening up these
pawns so that the king can escape
okay he's got ideas but are they the
right ideas you can also see how much
the how much effort they've put into
learning about chess
they were not playing like just like
this in the beginning used
my king to basically i just [ __ ] blocked
this bishop from coming here
now he's pinning me i can force him to
move his arse out of the way
that's unfortunate okay so now that you
know you're losing material
off the deep end that's something you
hate to see happen
when you're losing you sack in exchange
to try to get something else
i don't know why i did that i want to
get my rooks involved
so let's do that it's very much in his
style he's like yeah i could chase
checkmate but let me make sure all my
pieces are
involved here yeah anime man's down to
just the rook here
and it's just not gonna be enough to
come back from this one there's a lot of
ways to close this out for white
let's go there no i think that's checked
mate
does that checkmate then that's
checkmate
no it's not checkmate [ __ ] what'd i miss
what'd i miss
oh we can just take my [ __ ] rook i'm
an idiot i'm an idiot
i'm throwing i'm [ __ ] throwing he
remembers oh
no but i mean he still has a lot of
pieces to close this out and if this
comeback does happen
i am going to be nothing
okay yeah go ahead and take it
oh it gives up the rush oh are we in
salmon territory here
let's see let's see we are indeed in
every territory black's pawns can no
longer move so if the king has no
squares but it is not
in check it is stalemate and that would
be a draw
ah i really hope this doesn't end in a
stalemate if it ends in a stalemate i am
going to be
pissed only a few moves left
okay getting warmer definitely getting
warmer
joey god [ __ ] dammit why are you
being so difficult
this is so tense yep he's setting up the
ladder checkmate the king only has one
more
oh thank god and he
he has it he has it oh my god that was
so
stressful gigguk is taking the first
game now anime man has the white pieces
and uh
and a chance at redemption here he's in
a muslin situation maybe he studied a
little bit of my games
this is the rui lopez and oh he's
playing the berlin defense so
basically it's a grand master
i'm curious to see if we can hear how
anime man is dealing with that uh
loss in the first game joey's definitely
focused right now the past is the past
it seems for him in that first game and
you know what you were going to do
honing in
on how to improve his play
and his last chance i can call next time
look at this four pawns in the center
again i mean this is like the favorite
formation of the tournament arc
oh man there's a there's a lot of
questionable moves happening
right nothing stopping me from taking oh
wait that's no sorry
that was his pawn there trying to move
joey's pieces for him
[Laughter]
and now he has to take back with the
bishop yes he has to take that
no he has to take this bishop has to
take to make sure it's an evil trade
no joey he can take my queen that's fine
i'll take him with my rook
if you take if he takes with knight i'll
take with knight
but wait a minute now the script is
flipped on this exchange
we may have another one of those i
haven't messed up yet moments
oh yeah he's got the mouse over the rook
on a1 he saw that so now he's protecting
this pawn and this knight very smart boy
guard
very smart boy i can attack his rook now
though if he doesn't take that pawn okay
he's starting to show some full board
awareness himself
did he just let that pawn go because
after
black takes on d1 and white takes back
with the other rook the pawn falls
if he takes this pawn then he will have
the initiative because of that extra
piece
i don't like this one bit i wanted to
get rid of the pressure on there
oh bishop captures f7 i don't like that
movie yeah unfortunately it does not
work there are too many pieces defending
that square
not taking into account my knights that
almost panics me for a second
easy to play remember the goal of the
game is not to protect your pieces
the goal of the game is checkmate and
you have to find all possibilities
to checkmate your opponent one thing
you'll notice about his clock is there's
a lot of time on it which may suggest
he's moving a little too quickly man i
really want to like put my queen to some
good use
and here rook d6 is actually a fantastic
move
this is pretty much a grand master level
move
[ __ ] understanding that the a file is no
longer
being used and contesting the default
you see how this queen is behind
that knight is attacking right so you
think it's finned but actually here we
have a surprising move
you should always look for checks first
checks checkmate threats
captures right and you want to look for
forcing moves so actually the move here
was just to play knight f3 so that when
they take the knight
you take the rook plenty of pieces
attack that
is a free queen he cannot take because
of the checkmate threat yes
hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah free queen
let's go
let's go let's go
[ __ ] yes he took the bait
that was a [ __ ] hard one oh my god
and up next this is uh we're gonna do
something
a little unique we are actually going to
do a pre-match
interview with rustage and seadog they
both
told us behind the scenes last night
that they each have
a little something that they they'd like
to say before the games
and so we said well all right who asked
for this opportunity initially
he wants to chat his [ __ ] he wants to be
the big people guy
he wouldn't be the man i wanted to scare
my opponent before we get in the game
we are both [ __ ] ourselves but for
different reasons
i saw him tweeting out something like uh
it's uh david versus goliath
it is it is but david wanted that though
but so
what i forgot about that part
let me ask you i guess you got any
secrets up your sleeve your secret
weapons are you gonna unleash
all right so here's my plan when i heard
him play against nux at one time he was
panicking because he was running out of
time a lot i hope that i can just play
for long enough that he runs out of time
and i win on time i played knox and it
was the first games i played of chess in
like a few years
yeah cleaned up my game a lot since then
okay so i know you're i know you're
scared of the i know you're scared of
the clock daniel
i've seen your games okay you know what
i was i was
you know i'm flatless i'm hoping he
might [ __ ] himself in the middle of the
game
that's a very viable strategy at this
point dude this is it
they said they wanted team trash days
but restitch could throw a wrench in
that whole plant so what openings this
is the
salamander opening right yeah this is a
salamander opening
basically the accelerated london system
let's listen into the opening thoughts
slash
l'oreal commercial that is uh i can't
move this now he's also pinning me
because my queen's here but that's why
uh
oh i should have moved my queen up first
that's normally the play he's done this
okay i think i'm going to trade here i'm
pinning him i've got him in check he's
just going to take it but that's okay
i'm going to move my queen here
so that when i castle my bishops will be
communicating i wish my hair could do
that
yeah i'm probably saying all this like
it sounds smart it's really smart guys i
really want to take control of this
square but obviously he takes my queen
if i do that
no this is some this is really good
stuff but he's no longer protecting that
square which is the important thing
that's what i wanted to stop what's him
protecting that square what he's saying
is
really good you have to look at all of
the pawn breaks in the scenario right if
you don't look at the pawn breaks and
what a pawn brick is is where
you push a pawn to try to change the
pawns
oh oh my gosh no
oh wow and you you see he
look at rustic he can't believe it
oh oh oh and sea dog is eating it up
let's listen i can't believe he did that
he was going too fast rustage my boy
what are you doing i wonder if that was
a miss click or not i'm devastated
i'm absolutely devastated i mean hey
that's good storytelling right you get
the hero's gotta be down for the count
he's gonna take that unless i take him
what's the reason why i don't take that
i'm gonna lose this anyway so he's
forcing this
unless i put him in a position where i
could take something else
okay you know he said that he feels like
this game is already lost
but you know he's still talking about
the position like
he wants to play on anyways right do the
best job he can do here
and again when you are losing this is a
great characteristic to have
just be tenacious just keep playing and
keep trying to play the best moves
it's never over until it is officially
over how long is he gonna take to close
this one out i'd give him
four minutes see i took 30 seconds on
that it doesn't feel like i'm taking
that long clearly i am like that's a
move i should have done
instantly like in my games when i was
playing yesterday i wouldn't hesitate to
do that move i knew it was the right
like that's a good move
because i'm so far ahead i don't think i
need to worry about tempo like i don't
think there's a way that he can come
back into this if i
just don't allow him anyway to get into
it i'm just going to take three things
until i'm i'm i've won at this point
following the rule i mean this is
unfortunate he just blunted this queen
right away
no hesitation we just uh take i think
right russ is just gonna have to work
really hard in the next game i have a
little bit more patience
right i mean that that's what that queen
move was it was just it was just nerves
and a little bit of impatience
but look at rustic i mean if we peek in
on his stream he
is calculating he is looking for
possibilities so let's listen in i'm
absolutely lost i wonder if they're
spectating me right now being like
what's he gonna do
look at his little stupid little brain
not work right now
it's true my little brain's not working
my stupid little dummy brain is not
working i could move this
up and threaten the bishop i don't but
then he just takes it
and then he just takes it um [ __ ]
is there like a little light in their
rooms that tells them when we're
watching
that we don't know about sea dogs
obviously moved on already he's he's
already thinking about his opening moves
for game two
and there is a checkmate on the board
very nice finding it in quick fashion
oh that was even a game give me a game
i want to be scared okay [ __ ] we're
already getting in the game [ __ ] okay um
well rustic just
gonna give you a game here we go oh what
is that
a caro khan defense c6 and we're good to
go and so so far we have a great opening
and i think uh rustage is
taking a bit more time here and really
calculating and making sure that he
doesn't make a mistake
if he takes that i will just take back i
need to protect my
my pawn i wonder if he realizes that he
is using more time than me this game yes
which is good
i'm hoping he's thinking more and then
we have to go to the three-minute chess
and then we'll just both
panic i'm down on time but i think that
again if i'm careful with these moves i
can get to the point where i can
easily last on two minutes i think
what am i doing it's actually being
defended by pawn now so i think that's
now still a strong position
the problem with that is if he goes
there he puts me in check arrow game
strong
something wow finding it i'm going to be
amazing move in the position
oh my god man that was a great move he
spotted it
[ __ ] i'm really impressed i can't give
up the center
if i take this i give up the center i
need to make sure i have control of the
center still if i give up for the
control the center i think it's over for
me here we go
there's a small inaccuracy here and we
can
win a pawn he's definitely going to take
that back and now i'm threatening this
he's gonna take that and i have nothing
to do with that [ __ ] i can just take
there but then he just moves down if i
take his pawn he's just gonna take my
pawn back and i can't take it with the
queen it's really defended
don't be scared it'll be fun take the
train and he's making his move very
quickly
this is what i like to see on a fork oh
he found the fork yep
he's already looking for it uh-oh
great and now he has a material
advantage and
he got his rooks to the open file if you
don't defend that bishop on your next
move that's going next
sea dog may have just let rustage dig
his own grave
the sea dog know that he can't touch
that rook on d1
oh my god i feel bad man he's trying to
get this cheese checked
he sees it i know that's what he wants
he wants me to move
i'm not going to give it to him you know
what i'ma just let him know that he's
not having it
i do whatever i want you're just letting
me end is that what is it what he's
doing right now
okay i'm gonna go up here you just have
too many pawns
there is no cheese wait i gotta play the
music
[Music]
up conor's got something prepared i'm
not done i want him to know that i am
stronger another queen let's get another
queen he's got all right there we go
yeah he found it let's go that's it
fellas damn that was a
[ __ ] great game rough dudes man very
impressed we are ready
for our match between restage and the
anime man to begin
uh somebody's gonna walk away with an
extra
four hundred dollars in their pocket and
they're also going to walk away with
bragging rights [ __ ] up
immediately i did it on the wrong side
he already is saying he made a mistake
all right [ __ ] it i meant to do it on
this side i did it on this side because
i was practicing it as black
he did on the wrong side but it's okay
he hasn't messed up yet
sounds like i'm pointing out the object
whoa i'm sorry guys what was that did it
he did it he just took my queen
i should have paused and thought why did
he do that another queen blunder from
daniel rustage
i just found a really sweet pin if i
move this knight here and take this
knight
then i can swing in here he found it he
found it
see i'd like that move c4 again if we
have to forget the fact that we know the
bishop is hanging oh we can't forget it
[Laughter]
instantly i was gonna i was gonna say
that bishop's been now been hanging for
you know five moves so we have to assume
maybe anime man doesn't see it i was
wrong
okay i think i might just whoa whoa oh
that's what i was wondering what
happened i think i'm just
i'm retreating it my oh [ __ ] i did not
[ __ ] see that dog
i don't have any time to think if the
trade is good yeah that's good
actually and unsticks my rook nope
unsticks my rook but i still [ __ ]
lose it
ah all right
then he's giving up the pastor oh yeah
he could just take it
no i forget the queen the king can
actually touch him
over a king upon him with joey so i
think this is an easy
win for him oh there we go there you go
that makes it easy
and promotes with checkmates anime man
takes the first game of the match
[Music]
i'm on like self-destructive mode right
now because i
blundered really badly and now he has to
take with the horse and then we trade
queens
yeah you know what rust let's make this
game interesting dude
and c3 is hanging this is this this game
is could go either way i have zero clues
to make a prediction now i thought we'd
have a thai tie
a tie tie tie one one um
i'ma be a little tight after this match
i know you don't
yeah that's what i thought oh let's
check that's okay let's take that and
you'll probably just take this
that's fine too and i'm [ __ ] three
minutes ahead
if you're not going to take it i'm i'm
going to take this pawn and promote
that's what i thought he was going to do
okay then i'll just take this and now
his bishop's in danger again joey's
looking at all these sequences
it's impressive see if joey realizes the
giga brain
uh oh [ __ ] i'm just gonna take that then
start promoting what's funny is actually
uh rustage missed the wind the best
thing to do when the rook was actually
pinned was to just leave it frozen
and start pushing the h-pawn right away
and then black would have been winning
by force
now i don't know what's going to happen
it if black makes the right move here to
bring up the king
first then black is still winning but if
he pushes the pawn it's going to be a
draw i think
yes oh wow rustage just found that move
now short of some horrible blunder it's
an easy win you could put the bishop on
a8 which might be something he does to
sort of feel warm and cozy
right just run away in theory oh okay he
goes there that's
that's the wrong way to do it now you're
inviting the king up with tempe
yep have to take that he can't go down
like that but i can still just block it
please resign jerry joey offers a draw
checkmate
declines wow
he wouldn't be able to move and let's uh
let's listen as he
yeah thank god wow oh no now we've got
to go to the three-minute game
the relief and yes you're right you now
have to play
3-0 what great technique by the way wow
from rustage
oh oh my gosh rustage no
no no it's protected by this
i blunted so badly of course i did i
didn't have time to think i have three
minutes joey must be stuck to you as
well
let me just move quickly and not think
about it as much when it comes to speed
dude he's got me how can he do these
things so fast
tune is killing me on speed he is
killing him and uh
my goodness the anime man must be
feeling
pretty hot right now are you still
overwhelmed
okay okay okay oh no why did i do that
that was a bad move that was a bad move
i should have moved the rock oh i should
have moved the rook
[ __ ] in my [ __ ] but i think
regardless of the board
jt's training and bullet paid off
because look at the clock there's a
beautiful move to clean this up oh
oh my gosh 20 seconds left for message
oh you son of a [ __ ]
and restage is feeling it it's on it's
he's going to win on time
and let's listen in as uh
[Music]
let's go third place baby
trash taste top three let's
[ __ ] go i i don't know just start
throwing verbal hands let's go
why would i need to when i'm already
going to win that's
come on i mean like i'm i'm gonna scare
the [ __ ] out of conor so much that he's
gonna have to blame him on food
poisoning
and the first game of the tournament arc
final starts now
oh my gosh here we go
they always say don't bring your queen
out early right charlie we've told our
students that for years
but if you can put the most powerful
lady on the board in the middle of the
board and she can't be attacked why
would you not want your queen in the
center right
god this is a fiesta you might be right
danny that that queen in the middle of
the board might be frustrating him
looks like he's calculating his maniacal
evil plan
a good chin stroke is uh 101 for
evil geniuses so one of the things that
i told
gigak is that oh wow interesting uh
interesting oh i just gave him a piece
what am i doing gave up a piece and blew
out my eardrums
oh my god he didn't spot it oh my god
okay what the [ __ ] i'm just gonna take
it
sea dog dodged a massive bullet just now
um i guess now i can start trading right
he seems calm suppose he would want to
move his knight there to get my queen
off
yep he's quieter than he's ever been on
stream
yes i know that he can just reveal the
bishop yeah that's a great observation
jt this is
this is a more serious sea dog than
we've seen in this competition
i want to cut off this square though as
well for the bishop i don't want to
allow it to
go there and you can't get that right
now so i guess there's no point i don't
want to have this square though either
and also that huge blunder earlier
might have changed his psyche and said
hey i can't do this again this may also
be the first time conor's been
down on the clock in a match gigguk is
now in trouble
down a pawn and you know should be worse
but there's still the potential of
any anytime you have kings on opposite
sides of the board right
tactics galore always potential chances
for an attack and a blunder we'll see
what good comes up here
this is damn difficult
whoa that was a mistake right that was a
mistake by him recognizing
that it's a mistake he's given me an
opening he's giving me an opening
and now he's fighting is he sweating he
must be sweating this is really scary
if i were conor i would be so scared in
this position i'm throwing so hard
oh my gosh
what is happening it was made in one it
was made in
oh one god i didn't want to see anything
queen takes f8
lights out right yeah and it seems like
conor knows he's in danger but didn't
have a sense how much did he have time
though jack made
one second there's a second come on come
on okay i'm just going to start trading
pieces
oh my [ __ ] god
come on come on come on
game [ __ ] oh so that's history
gig has never beaten conor until now
conor the heavy favorite to win
tournament arc
is now down one nothing it's win or go
home for sea dog so
game two sea dog has the white pieces
and he must
win he cannot just draw he has to beat
gigguk right now i can't believe that i
can't believe it conor's still reeling
from that first loss
and look at giggook he's playing this
sort of suffocating chest that we've
seen him practice goes for a check
you should notice here that sea dog is
playing extremely quickly after 14 moves
only down 45 seconds
yeah he's got to be thinking on his
opponent's turn which is important
i think conor's sending us to our second
tiebreak of the day wow
did we not get the finale we wanted or
not people come on and i told you this
is going to be the highest
episode of the tournament i'm wondering
if he's breathing a sigh of relief
um it was definitely a sigh
yeah he can't do anything immediately he
knows his king is safe he's probably not
feeling too comfortable there's a fork
now obviously but there's no way he can
get it
like i said if he finds g3 h62 check
that's a fork right and he can't take
free rook find by me
oh what a turn of fence and now we're
back even now we're back even
let's go a healthy underdog mindset so
it's okay if you're winning to think
you're close to even
because as long as you're objectively
find the best move it doesn't matter
conor is
feeling the heat you know i would say
he's not letting it show but his silence
kind of says the whole story
this is the muta muda muda check after
check after check after check the
mistake end of the greatness ah okay
desperate for her gig to make a mistake
and he's not making one
uh i'm running out of time [ __ ] i'm
gonna be living on increments soon
that's that's bad i've
i've not got enough time to think about
this i'm just going to offer up the
queen trade you can take it if you want
it still puts me in a good position
because then i got my rook up here
connor issuing the check
first burns more time on gekko's clock
like queen trade yeah [ __ ] it
and conor five minutes on the clock i'm
gonna win this through increment now
okay gotta go gotta start planning this
out quick
the checks will keep coming making a
difference oh this is so [ __ ] tense
yes yes
oh my goodness oh man i can't say
anything this is crazy there's
just seconds on the clock white is
winning
is this that is this [ __ ] it nine of
them see it
he's just living on increment my pawns
are trapped in the corner
oh this game's lost there's nothing i
can do i've lost i've lost
he's emotionally divested from this game
as long as conor plays
good moves here he'll actually be fine
this is a really intense game wow yeah
dude
maybe he he realizes he still has a rook
uh oh he's putting a lot of pressure on
himself as well he is but he's not
moving too quickly he sees that he's got
three and a half minutes on the clock
you could hear a pin drop all the way in
tokyo
[Laughter]
oh and he cannot repeat if he repeats he
loses
oh boy remember the stakes everyone a
draw
wins the tournament for gigg
if he repeats with the knight to c5 it's
a draw
oh i don't know if he knows three move
repetition if black plays king c7 it's a
draw
[Applause]
no don't play king c7 please oh
my repetition what
can we see but wow
connor it's feeling oh my gosh
what how is that a drool by repetition
oh my god look who came in this room
oh my god what's chat saying what is
chat saying
this was the most anime
this was the most anime final you could
possibly hope for
[ __ ] unbelievable the protagonist
wins giga by repetition
oh my gosh who could have predicted this
and gentlemen
that was the tournament arc and i have
just one thing to say
gg baby let's go come on
you can't spawn without gg
i yes i did buy these drinks
specifically
for that moment we're not sponsored
these actually taste like piss
so uh yeah i'll tell you what these
taste like
victory they definitely do not taste
like victory
they don't it tastes really bad but it
was worth it for the joke
what an absolute opposite can i just say
what an absolute upset not just the
grand finals but i think my match as
well was a bit of an upset
that that last day was [ __ ] like
mental it was insane it definitely lived
up to the hype it never happened i'm
conflicted because at one part i'm so
glad that we put on like
an amazing show and story but on the
other half i just played terribly and i
wanted to win
so it's so it's so like [ __ ] i'm torn
i'm tall
the [ __ ] i watched your uh highlight
of you
just being like just playing so
confident being like all right i'm going
to move this pawn in and there's like
draw
and you're just like bruh
that was that was a real moment i think
i was mega tilted from the first game
and i started letting those mistakes add
up even though i was crushing on in the
second year yeah you were close yeah
yeah
i was like very confident i had won it
at one point but i think i just
remembered i still kept getting tilted
yeah yeah in the previous games i was
like yeah but why did i make that
mistake in that last game that was the
biggest like technical ko in that second
game too
it wasn't like a clean knockout in like
the first round no it was it was like
you just got gold experience requiems or
something like that yeah
that's just what happened but god beat
me one time in chess it was the one
your approach to the two games or like
how did you come
how did you feel coming into it ah fine
i don't know
i i think i i just felt i i know i
remember
thinking back i was like yeah for some
reason i wasn't thinking clearly
like normally i would i would see
everything yeah and for some reason
i just couldn't think more than two
moves ahead for this tournament it might
be this tournament i mean
it might have been the overconfidence it
might have been the fact that you were
[ __ ] yourself every five minutes
i didn't want to use that as an excuse
you know i mean it's a pretty valid
excuse
right yeah it was i don't know what it
was maybe it was the mixture of
everything right like not wanting to
lose
me talking so much mad [ __ ] before it
but that was on purpose to build up the
hype you know yeah
they did do oh yeah the pressure was
definitely on you
to it to win i i was just i was just
playing to have fun but the the one
thing that really pissed me off or not
pissed me off
till to be watching all your other games
is that not a single person like no
matter how close the game was no not a
single person ever pressured you
to like make a movie it was yeah because
my one my one game plan going into this
was
because we played twice off street yeah
i remember the one time you made a
mistake against me was when you were
like
i was like heavily pressuring you and
like putting under pressure to make
to go to go on the defense and so my
tactic for this was just
i'm just gonna try to put kind of under
pressure and see what he does and
like i think a lot of people went to
this tournament thinking you were like
untouchable unstoppable and i'm like
conor can make blunders
yeah giant blunders especially under
pressure yeah definitely and there's
never going to be a higher pressure
situation
than this because the only high pressure
situation was his [ __ ]
i i was really sad because the second
game as well i thought i was playing so
[ __ ] clean yeah i was absolutely
clean you were though
and then i just absolutely like threw
the game i was so sad there was there
was one move
where i i'd given up on my work
and i was just like okay i'm just going
to set up this attack on the left side
and i knew he was going to do it before
he even started doing it i knew he was
going to give up because there was
nothing you could do
you trapped me really well so i was like
okay instead of instead of worrying
about that and trying to mitigate damage
i'm just going to go
like all out persona 5 attack all out
and
like if conor plays this right he's won
but he made like one massive blunder
with that one pawn that i just kept
pushing up for some reason in my head i
mentioned this to you i was like three
moves before i move that pawn i told
myself i was like
i know i'm gonna have to push this pawn
when he does this move yeah and for some
reason i just completely forgot that
when i had to actually do the move
i just blended
you can literally see the bar flip from
like 90
of you to 90 percent of me with that one
move just because i'd set everything up
there was a lot of games like that this
tournament
okay anyone who's like talk [ __ ] it's so
much harder to play
on stream with like thousands of people
watching you because i have tens of
thousands of people i didn't play my top
game
oh no any of my games i'm not gonna lie
watching your guys's game even though it
was high level just the amount of missed
wins both of you missed i was just like
is this what it feels like this is what
it feels like
i understand now what it feels like to
[ __ ] watch my game
version yeah it's crazy i think my most
tilting moment in the entire tournament
was when i was trying to finish you off
in the first game yeah yeah
it was just so stressful because i knew
it was easy i knew it was easy because
i've done this a million times before
but for some reason when that that when
that time is counting down
and the clock's ticking and i know i'm
about one move away from like
stalemating this game
in my stream i was like dude i can see
it this is a mate in one there was a
maiden one
like five times and i'm just like please
just take me out of my mystery man you
are just
and you kept like hovering over
stalemate like tiles and yeah everyone
was like no
i'm just like what are you doing like at
this point i'm rooting for you to just
finish me off because i know i'm [ __ ]
yeah but not like everything about
this entire tournament like even the
first day right with the
the preliminaries was really [ __ ]
hype
i think everybody i think really enjoyed
it i'm so happy i got to use the on
person
yeah you even said that you're like
it was so [ __ ] scripted but yeah and
it was the finishing move as well
because that was the move that enabled
me to like checkmate jeff it was it was
beautiful jack didn't know it existed
i couldn't believe it i still love my
like my second round with d
where i just like i did the most
perfectly timed checkmate because
if you watch that on dee's perspective
it's one of the funniest things
that you've ever seen i think that's one
of my favorite clips about this
tournament just are you going
i don't think i've messed up this game
yet
it was brilliant watching your stream
you were like wait a minute yeah
you saw it and everyone was like yes yes
yes i saw your
big difference you was getting so hyped
you were like he sees it
the question is when is when is the hand
job coming yeah
man i saw stretch taste episode 69
i was watching back i'm like why are
people making so many hand job
like jokes in my stream like where did
that come from
and then i watched back on your mind
you're like if joey spots this checkmate
i'll give him a hand job i couldn't
think of anything but i'm like i'll just
say
it was but watching your first game was
with d was like i was
losing myself i was literally pissing
myself because it was just a game of
ints
oh yeah he was just giving you free
pieces he was like presenting his queen
and joey joey just doesn't say the
amount of simp jokes that came out of
that
joey doesn't want to take the queen
because he does he respects the queen
there's a chess simp that's so good and
like on the other side of the spectrum
you had rusted she played [ __ ]
amazingly like
rustage i feel was like the biggest dark
horse of this one
he's surprised he surprised a lot of
people um but then he would also just
give away his queen
in every other game the first game just
gave me his queen and i think it tilted
him too hard yeah because like his
second game
he was he was in a winning position for
like a good point
he just didn't know how to do anything
with it which is unfortunate because
like on my stream i was like please
don't do this move
he does the move and i constantly i'm
like please don't do this move it's an
amazing move he keeps doing it
i'm just like [ __ ] he was telling me
before uh our our match our third place
matt she was like dude i was having
nightmares about queen blonde
it actually i actually had a nightmare
and i was like if i do it again
i swear to god
as well like what was up with his setup
on his live stream
anime
because because obviously they had the
16x9 aspect ratio yeah yeah yeah on the
chess.com stream so it was even more
stupid
they just had like his forehead at times
it was so funny
oh my god oh my god i was so hyped and
like what how i'm really shocked at how
good like the chess.com stream turned
down oh yeah
it was so fun yeah it's so well done the
whole thing
came out amazingly yeah yeah considering
this came out as just a
like a throwaway tweet from um from just
us talking about chess in our podcast uh
it turned out to be a pretty [ __ ]
amazing event
i mean i think the real winner here is
uh my twitch account
i got like a thousand gifted subs bro
yeah i think
all of our twitches like everyone who
participated in the tournament got
an insane growth yeah dude i had never
had that many viewers in my life until
the time
you had like seven thousand yeah you got
more than like hikaru
yeah yeah i don't know why you're
getting more than the
that's how you make it entertaining
right but uh yeah he uh the
guy from chess.com said they're very
interested in doing a second one they're
very happy with the results tournament
arc season two
so tournament season two would you guys
like to see in season two that's the
real question though yeah one thing i
requested was i really want to see a
loser's bracket
i think a loser's bracket would make it
so hype because it's like all right
if someone falls out man like they lose
the bracket in this would have been
amazing
it's so funny like jeff versus yeah
there's so there's so many matchups in
here that i would have loved to see
oh yeah we just never got to see and i
feel like i feel bad for
john super ipad who had to play you in
the first round
right that that just feels bad and he
didn't even play badly no his first game
he played
he played really well yeah yeah i mean
he did get uh his training like
literally the day of the day before yeah
cause
i was like checking everyone's
chest.coms account like keeping checks
you know i want to see who's good and
that john literally didn't start until
the day
before so i was you know and and on
john's training the day before he didn't
know what castling was
oh my god so it was it was doomed he
pulled out the castle and
he thought that i wasn't taking him
seriously because i didn't castle right
for like the first like 20 moves
no i think it's just because he was just
like yeah i didn't need to
if you're keeping the pressure on it's
like i don't need a castle yeah yeah
yeah what are you gonna do attack me
yeah overall i think a successful
tournament absolutely
big big shout out to chess.com for
organizing this entire thing and
yeah we would absolutely be down to do
another one yeah shout out to aaron and
the coaches for
uh giving us your time and yeah letting
us clown around and make a fun story
thank you for letting us fund our gotcha
addiction further
do you know how many ten rolls that is
on archives bro
i bought jojo all right that's it bye
[Music]
you